the built up.
>> That's just true. That's just true. If
you ask like random person on the road
like why is pedophilia wrong? Like I
don't really think about why it's it's
wrong. If you ask some random guy why is
murder wrong? What is his obsession with
with feminizing Quean in this video?
Jesus Christ. Going on as the doxing
information of Willie Mack, his wife,
and where their wedding is going to be
is just playing in the background. I can
kind of see why Willie Mack came to that
conclusion. How
How is it fair at all to assume that
Willie Mack like, okay, if you just dug
into it at all? If you just dug into the
claim at all, there's no proof for it.
So, no, you can't understand it. You
can't understand it because you're just
going off of vibes
>> in order to dismiss everything that I've
said. And if so,
>> what have you even said? You've said
like he's a hypocrite because
[Music]
All right, I guess let's just watch this
hit piece.
35minute Queenman video. This mogs the
uh Is this Could this be the new
Queenman hit piece? Maybe.
Could this be the new the new epic queen
and hit piece?
better than Vincent Martin? Is this is
Gilded Pooh gonna do what Vincent Martin
couldn't?
That's the question we got to be asking
ourselves
while watching this 35 minute Queen and
Hippie. I did not pre-watch this. I
watched the first like minute and I was
like, "Okay, I want to watch this on
stream. This seems funny." So, let's
watch this.
>> If you've got an issue with my video, if
you've got an issue with something I
said, respond to it. Fire up a live
stream and react. Do a response video.
So today we're going to be talking about
some limey angloid Destiny knockoff that
bears the face of a man that lost
gallons to L.
>> Gallons. Jesus. Pints. Maybe.
Pints. Maybe.
>> If you've got an issue with my video, if
you've got an issue with something I
said, respond to it. Fire up a live
stream and react. Do a response video.
So today we're going to be talking about
some limey angloid Destiny knockoff that
bears the face of a man that lost
gallons to lollycon. And also on top of
that, he has a YouTube channel with a
little under 10,000 subscribers called
Quean. I don't know what the [__] that
means. It's probably Jewish or
something.
Very lowhanging fruit. Very lowhanging
fruit. Listen, I'm not going to act like
I'm a I'm a W comedian.
I'm not a comedian or anything. I'm not
going to pretend like I am. Okay,
listen.
I was actually in DMs with Straighter
Aid. You know what she told me? You know
what she said to me?
You know what she said to me? You know
what this straighter individual I almost
said [__] but I took back the tweet. I
took back the tweet, so I can't I'm not
going to say words like that anymore.
You know what I said to You know what
the straighter [__] [__] [__] I did
not mean to That was actually an
accident. That was actually an accident.
You know what this straight raid person
said to me?
I don't care that you tweeted that I'm a
[__] because that's true. But why did
you do it? I thought it'd be a funny
tweet.
For your sanity, I've watched it. Lio
convoy modded. What does that mean?
Leo Convoy did a watch party of a queen
hippie
w true that's bass that's epic you
should become a comedian I've considered
it so listen I'm not a comedian many now
to be okay
many people have been saying I should
become a comedian like like straighter
straighter has been saying this
straighter has been saying I should
become a comedian
but I'm not all right I but I do have
the authority to say that the Jewish
thing is very lowhanging fruit. Very
lowhanging fruit. All right.
>> Something. But I didn't really know a
whole lot about this guy. And up until
he made a reaction to one of my videos
that I wasn't even awake to entirely
witness, I didn't really care that much
about him. Well, in that video, I am
talking about a guy who four years
previously, when he was 17 years of age,
had groomed a 12-year-old girl whilst
simultaneously being in a pedo hunting
community. Que.
Wow. Weddedit.
Weddedit. Okay, this is a weddit. What
do I remember from that video? Not much.
Not much. I remember thinking it was
kind of like a nothing video.
like a video that was born out of spite.
Like, oh, I hate this guy. I'm going to
make a video on him rather than like
there's strong evidence. That's just
based on memory. Maybe we can watch that
video after this. I don't know. I don't
know, guys. I don't know, folks. I don't
know, moral folk. I haven't been live.
[__] Oh my god, I'm dying. I haven't
been live. I haven't been live in a few
days. All right. I'm relapsing. I'm
relapsing, folks. I'm relapsing, folks.
All What is this? 96 of you watching.
All 96 of you watching.
What are you saying in my chat? This guy
is giving me gay rape vibrations.
I chatter rape the messenger. Wow. Women
did not like my take at all. Not only
did he not like my take, in response to
one of the chatters in his stream, he
decided to, I guess, make excuses for
the groomer in question.
>> Dude, you're literally This is the
dumbest thing I've ever seen. The big
picture is they watch Peter hunting
content at the time as they're messaging
the mind. They knew it was morally wrong
and they still did it. This is exactly
what I mean. It's like knew it was
morally wrong. No one operates like
that, dude. To just look at it as they
knew it was wrong and they did it
anyway. Therefore, they're evil. It's
like such a [__] low IQ viewing.
>> What does that even mean, Queman? The
ent
>> what? Why do you act like you don't know
what that means? for the groomer in
question.
>> Dude, you're literally This is the
dumbest thing I've ever seen. The big
picture is they watch Peter hunting
content at the time as they're messaging
them. They knew it was morally wrong and
they still did it. This is exactly what
I mean. It's like knew it was morally
wrong. No one operates like that, dude.
To just look at it as they knew it was
wrong and they did it anyway, therefore
they're evil. It's like such a [__]
low IQ viewing.
>> What does that even mean?
Uh,
the person was severely uh Jesus Christ.
The person was severely autistic and
raised in an abusive household. Uh,
complaining of malnourishment. Lump
foul. Yeah, I I don't remember the North
video. I don't even know if I watched on
stream. I think I might have just
watched it through you through Queman.
through Quean for the folks in back.
>> Queman, the entire point of morality is
to stop you from doing things that you
>> The victim was a young teen. They're
like 12.
I believe it was 12 and 17, so like 5
years,
>> you know, is wrong.
>> If I remember right, I don't think any
nudes were exchanged. I think it was
just like ERP [__] which isn't, I
guess, good. Um, but I guess it's, you
know, not as bad as it could have been.
I want to reiterate this, by the way.
This wasn't a 17-year-old that should
know that grooming is wrong. This is a
17-year-old that for a fact absolutely
knew it was wrong because again, he was
I don't remember anything about this
North Jet. So, I can't even I can't even
say anything about this. I got to
rewatch that video. in multiple pedto
hunting communities. There is no
universe in which you saying people
don't work that way makes any sense.
Unless you're saying he doesn't deserve
the criticism he's received for doing
something he knew was wrong. That's a
really strange take. A take by the way
he
>> I'd also need to see more of the context
of what Quimma was saying. I feel like
this this one like 5second clip isn't
enough to like stretch out his entire
perspective or take on this. He expands
on here.
>> Most people
>> Oh, here we go. Okay. W
>> go go go up and they they're they're
like 12
and they what? They break something and
their mom shouts at them
and then they cry and she stops shouting
at them. Then they learn that if you act
sad people might give you an easier time
and then that behavior builds up and
then they become manipulators and all
like that's the that's how it works.
That's how most people are falling. and
how behaviors are formed.
People don't do this clinically. Most
people I'll say some people have a
particularly good loc like internal
locus of control and all that [__]
>> The guy made a video on Queman and still
won't have a public discussion with
them. No.
No. Gilded will talk to me on stream.
Why won't he talk to Quean?
[__] Where is God? What's this guy's
name? Poopot. Yeah.
Gilded Vlad. Vladimir.
Oh, I'm getting a DM from a special
someone. I think we might switch
content.
Oh, I've gotten an update.
Girl conversation by having a birth rate
debate with an Australian.
Okay, this is going to be epic. This is
going to be epic.
He's so cool. He's so epic.
>> So, they are able to do this. But most
people, the the unwashed masses, the
average [__] [__] out on the street
does not do an evaluation of their
behavior and what they believe to be
wrong on some consistent principle and
then change their behavior based on
that.
They are animals that operate on learned
behaviors.
the built up.
>> That's just true. That's just true. If
you ask like random person on the road
like why is pedophilia wrong? Like I
don't really think about why it's it's
wrong. If you ask some random guy why is
murder wrong? Like they're probably not
going to have a good answer for it.
That's not really like a bad thing. Um,
I get what Queenman's saying here, but I
guess it's like,
[__] I just don't remember what this
video I I don't remember what was in the
video. I think is the issue. And he's
not like framing it super well. I don't
know what was in the video
up over the course of their life. What
are you trying to say? Are you trying to
say that the unwashed masses are somehow
immune to criticism for doing things
that they know are wrong? No, but
they're immune to the to the one
criticism of you saying they knew it was
wrong and they knew why it was wrong and
all that [__] right? That that's the
point of that, right?
That's that's the point, right? random
random person can be criticized for
something, but they you you can't
criticize them for knowing like the
[__] specifics of why it's wrong and
then all that I think is the point of
what Queman's saying.
Just because they don't have a clinical
analysis of their own moral views, what
the [__] does that even mean? All this
comes off as is you excusing a guy who
groomed a 12-year-old kid. You're
>> Okay.
Okay. I hate pedophiles cuz I'm not one.
Let's go. Let's [__] go. Take that
giving right now is easily a take that
could be used to justify any instance of
grooming. It's not like this
[__] argued whether or not the
guy had groomed the kid. Like he
literally in the stream straight up
says, "Yeah, that's grooming."
>> I mean, yeah, that that is that is
grooming. I just, you know,
I don't know how much weight I put on it
cuz it's just so easy for teenagers to
end up doing stupid [__] like this when
they're mixed age groups. But we'll see
what else. The girl was 12. What the
[__] bro?
Every seriously idiotic thing he says
came after he had already acknowledged
that it is in fact grooming.
>> So like
a touch starve. They're talking about
being abused by their mother. The mother
certainly wasn't talking to them. Well,
identified cause me as abuse on their
own. They certainly certainly weren't
nice messages. I I can probably believe
that this was like
impoverished.
>> Impoverished. I have no idea if he grew
up poor. Neither do you. Why are you
injecting that into the conversation?
Quan. Disgenic.
>> Disgenic. No comments on the disgenic.
He agrees with the disgenic line.
Malnourished, abused.
Little weirdo,
basically. So, first off, we have no
idea as to whether or not he was
malnourished as far as the
I mean to be I could be wrong.
[__] [__]
H
Didn't Gilded Friends Becket have a
similar take of what?
>> Touch the conversation. Quan,
>> hygienic,
malnourished, abused,
little weirdo, basically. So, first off,
we have no idea as to whether or not he
was malnourished. As far as a touch
starved claim, well, that was the guy's
excuse for having groomed a kid in the
first place, as seen in this clip.
>> He was just a kid himself.
Uh,
I mean, that's probably my take.
Again,
the the line between 17 and 18 is almost
non-existent. So, I don't think like
just because he's 17, it suddenly makes
it fine that he was messaging a
12-year-old. Um, but at the same time, I
think when you're a teenager, um, you're
probably going to do stupid [__] And I
think if this behavior,
again, I [__] I forgot the specifics of
the story. If this only happened once
and then he didn't do it again, I don't
really care. Who cares? But if this is
like repeated behavior, like he's
specifically targeting people
significantly younger than him, right?
That would obviously be an issue. I just
don't remember enough about this story
and he's not really doing like a TLDDR
about it. We're kind of I feel like we
have to watch this. We might have to
watch this video and stretch out the
stream an hour.
No,
>> but I can remember
touch starved during that time period.
>> So yeah, Queman just ran with that. And
as far as the abusive household or the
abusive mother, well, that's based
entirely upon this screenshot, which is
literally just
my abusive mod.
Abusive mod. [__] Abusive mom.
Just a teen doing stupid [__] can grow
out of it as an adult. No. Yeah. I mean,
it's the same thing with like Doc on the
Radio. When Doc on the Radio dated a
13-year-old at 17, people are acting
like um people are acting like that's
the end of the world, uh like no, he's
still realistically like a a kid. I
don't think I don't think things that
you do when you're like teenagers even
to early 20s depending on what it
obviously if you're [__] like blowing
people's heads off with a [__]
shotgun obviously like maybe that's a
little bit different. Um but like things
socially when you're doing things
socially to people I don't really think
it should be held against you to an
insane amount of uh scrutiny. Like at
the time, sure,
[__] scrutinize the person, whatever.
But like years after the fact, who cares
what you did when you were 17 or when
you were like 20 or when you were like
15 or 14? Who who cares?
Who cares?
You know, who gives a [__] Obviously,
there's lines to it, though. If this guy
was go I again I need to [__] watch
the original video because I don't
remember if this was a pattern or if
this was only one person. If this guy
was going out of his way
uh if this guy was going out of his way
to specifically target people like
significantly younger than him,
obviously that changes things for me.
But if this is just a one-time thing and
he uh didn't do it again, I don't really
care. Like it's bad. Say it's bad, but
like they need to be killed over it. I
don't know. Probably not. just his mom
telling him to stop whining and to do
his [__] chores because the little
[__] brat when he was like 15 or 16
had told her that he wants to get paid
for doing all this work and was acting
like doing chores was somehow like
slavery. That's what Queman is basing
the abuse allegation on. But
>> is he I don't even know if he's seen
that screenshot. Was that in the video?
It might have been. Somehow Quean
manages to make it even worse in the
following clip.
>> A teenager talking to a faceless user
online. Look, they have a man in real
life. No concept of what this
12-year-old is actually like of them
actually being a 12-year-old, like a
physical 12y old.
It's like if you can't if you are so
lacking in any sort of basic empathy or
you're so deranged by some [__] that
happened to you as a kid or you're
so optics cocked that you cannot
possibly imagine
how an autistic
abused 17-year-old that escapes online
could end up having inappropriate
interactions with someone too
>> doesn't this guy is really hellbent on
defending this this idea of an abused
child who escapes to the internet and
then accidentally grooms a 12-year-old.
Listen, I'm not I'm not pointing
fingers, okay? This Queen guy is very
hellbent on this abused 17-year-old
argument. This malnourished Quean also
says I I remember I think a few streams
ago he said he only eats like 600
calories. He said Queen only eats 600
calories. He said this abused,
malnourished
17-year-old who escapes to the internet.
H
[Music]
interesting interesting too young
without it being pedophilia.
If you are so lacking in any basic
[__] reasoning that you can't
understand that, you are the sort of
person that we need to cast out into the
[__] wastes. Seriously. So, number
one, whenever he says they never met, it
wasn't for a lack of trying. They
literally were talking about meeting up
in the screenshot.
What are your plans when we meet? What?
Okay.
Like, this is [__] people do all the
time where they're like, "What? What are
we going to do when we meet?" Dude, I've
done this [__] to Gamma.
Gamma, when we meet, I'm going to I'm
going to take you to Burger King or some
[__] right? Yeah, I I say this [__]
like [__] Dude, I' I've literally
said this to Queen like when we meet,
I'm going to [__] I don't remember.
Okay, but like this it doesn't mean
anything. Okay, there's like it's like a
credible It has to be credible, I think.
Right.
I'm like dying right now. Holy [__] It
has to be credible, right? Credible
plans to meet is not just saying like
when we meet, what do you want to do,
right? A credible plan to meet is like
scheduling dates, looking up flight
tickets, you know, making like an actual
plan, stuff like that. Just saying
off-handedly like after you're done
eexing or in the middle of [__]
esexing or whatever, you're like, "What
are we going to do when we meet up?"
It's like, "Okay, you know,
this isn't like credible." It's like
death threats, right? If you just say,
"I'm going to kill you." that obviously
lacks the impact of a credible death
threat where you're like actually
planning out the crime and you know
going into detail about how you're going
to [__] kill the person or whatever,
right?
So like for all intents and purposes,
for all intents and purposes, um
like no, they were not planning to meet,
especially if you didn't know what they
looked like. I would never meet up with
someone if I didn't know what they
looked like physically. like autistic
[__] uh North guy. So, who knows
>> that he had seen by this point in the
video. So, he's just being deeply
disingenuous about the seriousness of
this.
>> Oh, is there another screenshot?
I dare you to tell me what would you
lose your virginity to her? A candle w
>> by this point in the video. So, he's
just being deeply disingenuous about the
seriousness of this situation. Secondly,
more importantly than that.
>> Okay. No, Gila. It's like rape threats
is the It's It's not kiss. It's like
rape threats. Like when I meet you, I'm
gonna I'm gonna do something bad. Okay,
that's that's Come on. Don't we We don't
appreciate slander in the chat. Misinfo
is not appreciated on the morale live
channel. Okay, come on.
>> If you're going to sit here and talk
about empathy ad nauseium, why is it
you're only showing empathy for the
groomer in this situation and not the
12-year-old kid?
>> Queman's Crusade. Uh-oh.
very long title card.
>> And so for the meat of this video, we're
going to be discussing the Queenman
versus Willie Mack drama that's been
>> Whoa.
What is this guy's obsession with
feminizing Queman?
What is his obsession with with
feminizing Quean in this video? Jesus
Christ.
>> Going on.
>> Oh, the Willie Mac. Okay, I am probably
This is probably where I'm going to
[__] throw a [__] fit, dude.
Ter, this is He's going to have some
terrible takes about the Willie Mac
[__] I just know it. Aw.
All right, here we go.
>> For a little while. Calling it a drama
is a bit dishonest, however, because the
reality is it's just a [__] moral
crusade. So, the core of this drama is
that Destiny
>> moral crusade. I don't know.
>> Had sent a Google Drive to a girl that
he did not confirm the age of. a Google
Drive that contained pornography that he
recorded that he shared without the
consent of the other people in
>> It was more than just a Google Drive. To
be clear, it was more than just a Google
Drive.
It was more than just a Google Drive. He
sent individual videos.
God, I wish I just [__] God. Okay, I
need to I need to put out my video so I
can stop [__] Where is it? Is it
this?
It's this.
I don't think I have much BJ stuff
recorded. Ooh, there was a girl once. In
parenthesis, Pixie, she was so she was
young, so she was kind of new and wasn't
good, but she would just hold on to uh
hold on to me and tongue the head a lot,
which actually ended up feeling good.
Lol. But no, come shot. Do you want that
video? I'd love it. OMG. And he sends
the the video of Pixie.
Why do you have this preloaded? Cuz I'm
making a video on the Destiny stuff. So,
I have the file like is it quick
selected in the file explorer?
I have multiple multiple screenshots.
What is this one?
Yeah, here's this. I have their a
screenshot of their of the lawsuit
thing.
Wawsuit screenshot
said,
>> but it was more it was more severe. This
is I feel like this is uh I feel like
this is downplaying a little bit.
Like no, it was not just a Google Drive.
Like you haphazardly send a Google
Drive,
but whatever. Semantics. Semantics.
Sure. Semantics.
>> This has resulted in a lawsuit and has
been a
>> Can you show your thumbnail? Uh
yes. Where is it?
>> Who at this point had made 50s something
hours worth of content going over the
Destiny drama decided he would then
purity test Beckett over this [__]
Willie Mack video that apparently he
didn't like very much. I'm asking for
you to engage with like the statements
that being made. If a video fails on its
central premise, is it not by definition
a bad video? You say you're doing
>> How is this purity testing?
I will max.
>> Okay. To be okay. He's also missing out
on so much. Holy [__] I'm the one I'm
the one who called Becket and started
autistically debating him. Okay. I'm the
one who called Becket and started
autistically debating him because I
think Becket has principles uh that he's
unwilling to, you know, enact upon. He's
like, he's soyced himself. Becket has
cucked himself by trying to [__] do
the gay hypocrisy hunting and not just
saying like this is bad because it has
bad research. Uh Becket in his videos,
the thing that makes his videos good or
the thing that he says makes his videos
good is the research aspect. So I felt
in my mind, okay, if he cares about
research, then he should look at this
Willie Mack video that was poorly
researched uh and and say that it's bad
and say that yeah, bad research, bad
video, whatever. Um obviously that he
did not care. He did not give a [__]
Uh, and then Quimman joined like
afterwards
cuz I was trying to make the I was
trying to get Becca to concede that the
video is bad. Queman joined afterwards
and then did did this basically where
it's like, okay, if the video fails in
its fundamental premise da da da is not
purity testing. Okay, this is [__]
Very [__]
Decided to make a video going over this
very topic. and Queman, who at this
point had made 50s something hours worth
of content going over the Destiny drama,
decided he would then purity test
Beckett over this [__] Willie Mack
video that apparently he didn't like
very much.
>> I'm asking for you to engage with like
the statements that
>> Yes, he didn't like it because he lied
in the video.
He didn't like it because he li I I I
didn't like it because he lied in the
video. He didn't like it because he lied
in the video. He probably likes it for
more reasons, more more fleshed out
reasons. But yes, the video is bad. The
video is [__] The video is terrible.
It is a bad video. He spends the latter
half of it talking about [__] Becca
and Sunday for some reason when it's a
video about Destiny's allegations of
non-consensual, you know, revenge porn,
whatever you want to call it. So, yeah,
it's a [__] video. Willy Max sucks
>> being made. If a video fails on its
central premise, is it not by definition
a bad video? You say you're doing
something and you don't do that thing.
Unless there's an intentional
subversion,
I don't see how you can say that's not a
bad video. He failed on his central
premise. That's it. That's it. That's
where the point begins and ends. Now, I
understand, Becca, you can't call this a
bad video because you're in a total
[__] chokeold here because the video
criticizes you. So if you say it's a bad
video, you look like a spiteful [__] to
these commentary cabal people. So you're
in a total bind. You literally can't be
honest about this at all. You're in the
cabal's pocket where you're like, you
know, you can't say anything too crazy
or you won't say anything too crazy.
You're like,
>> "Oh, I like all these people." That's
you.
>> Well, I do like people. Sure. And I
mean, that's me admitting a bias, isn't
it?
>> No, it's not just admitting a bias. It's
like I like all these people, so I'm
opting to have every conversation about
it. Um, well, I'm clearly engaging in
this conversation.
>> I would make it so you have to pull
teeth to get anything close to a
condemnation. You have to sit there and
ask me. If a video fails on its central
premise, is it a bad video 60 times?
>> Well, I mean, again, you said this
earlier as well. I It's not just the
cabal. Like, it's a video that has
criticisms of me in it, right? And like,
I kind of don't want to rehash this.
>> If it was like a Nick Dior video, just
any given Nick video, I think it'd be
the same. understand that this is like
why I'm saying I'm using the word
spineless, right? There's clips of moral
talking about how he wants to [__]
17-year-olds getting bunched on YouTube
drama and you're sitting there being
like, "Oh, well, if I criticize Nick
Dioro in the wrong way, then I might
die." It's like I that's this is
>> Well, it's not that I might die. It's
just annoying to deal with.
>> It's just a very obvious problem that's
going to annoy people when you're being
asked a question. You're ostensibly
having the conversation. You're being
asked a question and you're not actually
answering it. You're not actually
engaging with the point.
>> Okay. But I but I said but I but hold
on. But this is the thing. That's my
statement or my response to it was never
enough.
>> I think it's really dumb to go up to
people that you claim to like and then
tell them that they should take your
side in some stupid moral crusade that
Okay, that's not what happened though. I
did that. Quan didn't do that. I did
that. I'm the one that did that. Holy
[__] Okay, this sucks. This sucks. To
be clear, I'm the one that went into the
VC and started moral fagging to Vlad or
not to Vlad, [__] to Becket and being
like, "Hey, you should you should
dislike this video because of the
principles that I think you have."
Whatever. I'm the one that did that.
Quan didn't do that.
Quan asked Quimman like went in from my
understanding and was like, um, and from
memory I guess, [__] months ago. Jesus.
That was like towards the beginning of
the year at this point, like February, I
think.
Quan went in and was like, "Okay,
Becket, by your standards, this video is
bad. It failed at its fundamental, you
know, its premise. It failed at its
premise of what it was trying to do."
And then Becket agreed. It's like, "No,
he's not asking you to take the side of
like Willie Mack is a [__] bumbling
retard," which he is, to be clear. He
is. Uh, but he's he's obviously saying
like, "Becket, you should say this video
is bad because of the principles that
you have. You you have described this
video as being bad. You're just refusing
to say it's bad is my understanding.
Okay. This is not a moral crusade. Also,
this is not a moral crusade.
It is a bad video because he lies in it.
It is a bad video because at the end he
says, "Oh, I still respect Destiny and
there's no pattern of behavior of him
abusing women." It is a bad video for a
multitude of reasons, not just because
of of of one aspect or another and not
because of any moral aspect or
Yeah, I don't know about moral, but
whatever. You know what I mean?
It is a bad video. It is a fundamentally
bad video. Willie Mack says some in
insanely stupid [__] in it uh in the
first one and in the second one and he
should be criticized for it and he
should be lambasted for it because he
made a terrible [__] video about
Destiny.
Willie Mack is compromised. Willie Mack
was compromised. I don't know about
anymore. I don't know about anymore, but
at the time, 100% he was 1,000% he was
1,000% 1,000%.
1,000% smile.
>> You are hosting as if they are supposed
to give a [__] as if you are entitled
to them sharing your opinion. And in all
honesty, this wouldn't be the biggest
deal in the world if it weren't for the
fact that this has happened multiple
times. I mean, imagine for a minute
actually getting into arguments with
people you're friendly with online over
their opinion of some random YouTuber. I
mean, serious, that's the whole point.
That's the whole point. Are you just
Okay, dude. This whole mindset of like
you can't criticize people you're
friendly with or you can't criticize
your friends, it's so [__] [__]
Oh my god. Who cares? 1,000%, dude.
Dude, I'm not going to be complicit if
my friend sits there and he he he thinks
like the most rettored,
bumbling, mindnumbing thing ever.
Absolutely not. What the [__]
Yes. Criticize people you like or you're
friendly with. Who cares?
I would want I would rather people
criticize me than than [__] just
glaze me a thousand%. Like what?
No. Yes. Criticize your friends. Dude,
this whole this who I I don't know where
this mindset has come from. It has to be
like Nick Dioro or some [__] This new
mindset of like if you criticize your
friends, you're a snake is so [__]
mindn numbing. Holy [__] Yes, you can
criticize people you're you're friendly
with or you're cordial with. Who cares?
Here is yet another argument that Queman
had over Willie Mack with somebody that
wouldn't fall in line with his point of
view of Willie Mac.
>> If he made one done [__] on him,
which that first video did [__] on him,
then that's enough to
>> Whoa, whoa, whoa, no. Okay, so the first
video did point out some things Destiny
did wrong. It didn't [__] on him at all.
That's totally untrue.
>> A few moments later.
>> If your point is that he's not [__]
on Destiny, that is incorrect. His
videos are doing that. So yeah, I'm
gonna bring that up every time because
you keep saying something Destiny, but
I've never said you didn't show Destiny.
>> Quan gives the very absolute statement
of it is absolutely untrue that Willie
Mack at all shhat on Destiny. That in
>> one [__] on him, which that first
video did [__] on him,
>> then that's enough to no. Okay, so the
first video did point out some things
Destiny did wrong. It didn't [__] on him
at all. That's totally untrue. a few
moments later.
>> If your point is that he's not [__]
on Destiny, that is incorrect. His
videos are doing that. So, yeah, I'm
going to bring that up every time cuz
you keep saying something Destiny, but
I've never said you didn't show Destiny.
>> Quan gives the very absolute
>> Okay. I mean, [__] I feel like
I feel like that's missing context, but
whatever. Okay. I would say I would say
my point against Willie is he's very
soft on Destiny. He is inconclusive and
he tries his best to paint Destiny as
redeemable when he wouldn't do that for
anybody else. He would not do that for
Hassan. He would not do that for Andrew
Tate. He would not do that for
uh he would not do that for [__] Vos
or any of these people, right? Uh this
is exclusive to Destiny. And then
furthermore, he says Destiny uh doesn't
have a pattern of behavior of abusing
women. He is directly downplaying
directly downplaying what is going on in
those video or what what is going on
with Destiny and in in terms of women,
right? Willie is downplaying what
Destiny is doing. Willie is in effect
like it is it is extraordinarily soft on
on on these people,
right?
So, does it [__] on Destiny? Like where
it needs to, where it absolutely is
forced to. Yes.
Um,
but like overall it is very generous to
Destiny. He wants to give Destiny a path
to redemption where nobody else would. I
don't know about these two clips. I feel
like I'm missing context there. I feel
like I don't know. I'd have to watch the
Twitter call. This is the same thing
with the [__] North video. I feel
like I'm just missing so much. statement
of it is absolutely untrue that Willie
Mack at all shhat on Destiny that entire
video. And about 15 minutes later,
Quimman completely contradicts that with
the completely opposite statement that
he never said that. So either he
realized he [__] up during the
argument or he completely forgot he said
that. Either way, very high IQ. And with
that said, Queman's gay little crusade
is not limited to little nobody
[__] Here's a handful of
screenshots of him just going
>> I'm telling you directly that I think
the uh the community's criticisms Willie
for example weren't worthwhile. Some of
them hinged on being completely
contrarian. This isn't uh none of them
hinged on being contrarian. By the way,
this isn't me giving the game away. It's
just me being honest and saying it's not
really worth my time. I'm telling you
that you're behaving exactly like the
type of loser you would farm for a year.
saying attacks on Willie are gross and a
harassment campaign after being totally
dangled uh on the substance by Aug. I
mean, what what's wrong with this
>> psycho on Nicholas Dioro for not joining
>> psycho? These are just who cares? This
is tweets. What?
>> His side. And although I'm sure there's
a plethora more examples of all of that
that we don't have time to go into
today, I need you to simply bear all
that in mind. As we move on to the
doxing of Willie Mack and his wife did
not originate my docs. He maliciously
spread it everywhere. But my docs
originated on a niche form by this guy's
unhinged viewers. So when I see this
clip, it's obviously a dog whistle to
[__] with me. He literally gets a
donation that says, "I understand what
we must do." Wink wink.
>> Okay, so right up front before we deep
dive into that, I need to make a couple
things clear. Number one, there is zero
evidence to substantiate that claim. As
a result of that, I'm not going to make
that claim. Point two is I kind of
understand where they're coming from. I
kind of get it. Even though I don't
agree with it, I understand. Well, what
do I mean by that? Well, let you see
really.
>> Okay. What does he What does he even
say? Hold on. to the doxing of Willie
Mack and his wife.
>> Bad empanada did not originate my docs.
He maliciously spread it everywhere, but
my docs originated on a niche form by
this guy's unhinged viewers. So when I
>> by this guy's unhinged viewers, okay,
where's the notepad? Where's the [__]
notepad? Time to get autistic. Time to
get [__] autistic. Holy [__]
Gilded Pooh says he understands why
Willie thinks his docks originated
from Kiwi Farms by Queman's fans.
All right. Okay.
>> I see this clip. It's obviously a dog
whistle to [__] with me. He literally
gets a donation that says, "I understand
what we must do." Wink wink.
>> Okay. So, right up front, before we deep
dive into that, I need to make a couple
things clear. Number one, there is zero
evidence to substantiate that claim. As
a result of that, I'm not going to make
that claim. Point two is, I kind of
understand where they're coming from. I
kind of get it. Even though I don't
agree with it, I understand. Well, what
do I mean by that? Well, first, let me
play you the full clip and let you see
really what the subject of discourse
really is.
>> Destiny actually uh uh called for my
death, said he he would he would kill
me. Uh there is actually a moment in
this video it shows Destiny attempting
to dox me as well. Obviously I'm not the
only person this has happened to.
Now
something a little interesting. I saw
someone tweet out
a fellow by the name of little little
Steve tweeted something very interesting
out.
Little Steve.
Massa Massa Stevie
said
anything involving this bad empanada guy
or anyone that supports him is
justifiable. Mo anything is justified
against bad empanada and anyone that
supports him. Well, let's apply those
standards. Why are we saying this about
bad empanada? Well, it appears to me
because bad empanada
>> bracing for the most [__] take.
>> So would Destiny be saying
that those who
dox people,
those who make calls to violence or
illusions to violence should be fair
game. And all of their supporters and
all of their supporters.
>> Just rip the band-aid off. Come on, man.
Just rip it off. All the chatters that
back him up, everything
are just everything against these
people. Anything is justifiable. That
seems to be the standard to me is that
anything is justifiable against Destiny
and the people who support him.
No. Is that not the standard?
That's that's what he's laying out for
me here. Now, I have principles. I have
principles. I don't think it's no bad
tactics, only bad targets. That's not
me.
But Destiny is very clearly laying out
that those are the standards that he
believes in. Those are the standards he
he wishes to be enforced. Is if you're a
doctor, if you call for violence,
anything is justifiable against you, you
supporters.
>> Order taken.
>> Okay, that's not what I'm saying, Max.
Actually, I just explicitly said
otherwise, actually, Max, but Destiny is
clearly laying it out for you. Destiny
is clearly laying it out. He is saying
this type of
>> Very long [__] clip. Holy [__] is
justifiable.
That's what I'm saying here.
>> Yeah. So, the fact that he is sitting
there smiling from ear to ear as the
doxing information of Willie Mack, his
wife, and where their wedding is going
to be is just playing in the background.
I can kind of see why Willie Mack came
to that conclusion.
Willie Matt came to the conclusion that
he was doxed by Queenman fans because
the clip has Quean smiling.
[Music]
How
How is it fair at all to assume that
Willie Mack like, okay, if you just dug
into it at all, if you just dug into the
claim at all, there's no proof for it.
So, no, you can't understand it. You
can't understand it because you're just
going off of vibes.
I I
Dude,
okay. All right. Even though I don't
agree with that conclusion, especially
due to said lack of evidence, I can
understand why it kind of looks
>> No, you can't understand it. Him smiling
behind the clip does not mean anything
when there is literally no evidence.
This is why M will never face cam. He'll
never keep a straight face. I smile a
lot. I'm I'm a smiler. They call me the
smiler. that way. If I had to critique
Willy Mack a little bit, I would say
that if you really wanted to make the
accusation of dog whistling, this would
be a better clip. No bad tactics, only
bad targets, right? Just Just go the go
the full way. [__] it, man. Start
contacting Reddit service providers.
Start Let's just start attacking
sponsors. Let's just start attacking
sponsors all the time, actually. What
does Let's start calling Raycon about
how Willie Mack hangs out with um with
with sex predators. With sex predators
and people who sweep for sex predators
cuz no bad tactics, only bad targets,
right? We're we're about the goal, not
the method, right?
[Music]
Call get Raycon on the line. Get NordVPN
on the line. Dude, is this guy? He's
Okay, bro. How much for face cam? It
would have to be a lot of money.
Uh, I don't want to sacrifice my privacy
for [__] 50 concurrent viewers. Not
yet. Maybe if I maybe if you guys start
donating a lot. If I start becoming uh
if I start becoming a millionaire from
YouTube, I'll I'll I'll cam up. Sure.
>> They still
>> I mean, dude, I I I feel I feel [__]
even after having to [__] explain
this. He's laughing at the absurdity.
He's laughing at the [__] absurdity.
He's laughing at the absurdity. Yes,
it's absurd to think this. It is
insanely absurd to think that no bad
tactics only bad targets is like a real
thing. Obviously, am I am I Wait. Okay.
What is he What is neck? Let's get that
[__] canled. No bad tactics, only bad
targets. Obviously, I'm joking.
Obviously, I'm joking.
I don't think it's no bad tactics, any
bad targets. That shouldn't be the case.
But that's what these people have
adopted. Let's be real here. The
following is pretty much the exact same
clip.
>> These people deserve rape. That's what
>> what
what is going on?
What what
>> I guess that shouldn't be the case.
First of all, these people have adopted.
>> Let's be real here. The following is
pretty much the exact same clip. These
people deserve rape. That's what they
and I disavow rape, but it is what they
deserve. What did there was?
[Laughter]
Dude,
is Gilded online? I DM'd him and he did
not respond.
He is not responding to my DMs.
[Music]
Jesus.
Oh my god.
[Laughter]
Scared.
Okay. Obviously those aren't the same.
Those are not the same.
Queen is criticizing Destiny's argument,
Destiny's position of only bad tactics
or only bad [__] targets. No, no bad
tactics or whatever. He's criticizing
that by laying out how [__] absurd
and [__] it is. That's not the same
as Nick Fuentes.
I mean,
okay. Okay. Oh, Jesus.
Jesus Christ.
Okay. Whatever. Whatever. Whatever. I
mean, I think um Queenman's pro rape.
I'm sure. I'm sure. Listen, the old DGG
logs, folks.
There's some gems in there. Okay. If if
Vlad really wanted to make Never mind
the same as what Nick Fuentes did, which
was do the whole I disavow meme. You say
exactly what you're thinking. You throw
in, oh, I'm obviously joking, or I
disavow. You just sprinkle that in there
so that whenever somebody
>> Okay, again, but he's laying out why
those arguments are absurd. It it is
absurd to contact uh sponsorships. It is
absurd to contact or to dox people or to
do all of these things that affect uh
you know them monetarily or them um you
know, socially in the real world in
terms of like doxing because that could
affect family members, that could affect
jobs, that could do all of this [__]
right? It is absurd to to con to go to
those links to [__] with someone. That
is bad to do. That is wrong to do. That
is, you know, absurd to do. That is on
another [__] level, right? Um and
he's trying I I feel like pretty
obviously he's laying out why that is
absurd to do.
And why Destiny is obviously, you know,
hypocritical for acting as if bad
empanada is unique in doing this when
Destiny himself
also does this.
Okay, King Cole to be I don't think he's
grandstanding over rape jokes. Maybe. I
don't know. Gilded Pooh has the whole
Gilded Pooh's entire content is
basically just hypocrisy hunting because
he makes it a point to not morally
critique anything.
Um, he makes it a point to not morally
critique anything. He does not have any
moral standards. He does not care about
child rape or child grooming unless it
happens to his kid, for example, stuff
like that. So, um I'm going in under the
impression or under the assumption that
he's not he's not doing um any any moral
arguments here. I'm under the impression
he's just doing like hypocrisy hunting,
I guess,
but it doesn't really seem that way in
this video. I don't know. I don't know.
I've had multiple conversations with
Gilded Pooh. I think he said some
[__] [__]
I think Gilded said some insanely
Um, but the issue is you can't really
argue with him because he's trying to do
[__] hypocrisy [__] right? So, it's
really difficult to argue with him.
>> He calls you out on it. You can come
back with, "Well, you're being
dishonest. You're clipping that
dishonestly." I
>> because you are because he's trying to
lay out the absurdity of those
arguments, right?
>> He said somewhere in that rant that I
disavow or I was just joking. And but
it's not okay.
Whatever you got, I've already made my
argument here. I'm I'm I'm not going to
keep pausing every five seconds for
this. You know what I mean? Like, yeah,
obviously no. He's not He's not saying
like, "We got to [__] kill this guy."
I disavow, by the way, why Destiny's
argument is absurd by showcasing the
absurdness of it. I feel right. I mean,
I think that's pretty obvious, but we'll
keep going. We got to We can't We can't
We can't pause Andy. Okay, this is a
35minute video. We got to go all the way
through. All right. And that is in all
honesty why it is that people are
accusing you of dog whistling. Like
that's a large part of it anyway. And I
[Music]
People are accusing him of dog whistling
because they don't understand that he
was trying to accuse Destiny of being a
hypocrite.
I'm I'm going to [__] lose my mind,
dude. I'm going to [__] lose it. Holy
[__] I
>> can kind of understand where they're
coming from there because that's kind of
what it feels like. Even though again
there's no evidence to substantiate the
claim. And I know for a fact that Queman
is fully aware that the I disavow or
it's a joke guys meme is complete
[__] And the reason I know he is
fully aware that it is complete [__]
is simply speaking because he just today
on the 22nd of August at the time of
recording released a video where about
15 minutes in he is using a strange
whataboutism where he's like why are
people upset over Hassan and not upset
over this? People pick up on this one so
much and not the red bar clip. You know
that is interesting isn't it? I still
I've not heard anyone disavow this yet.
>> Heila game where she's lying on the
ground and we see how many people could
break into her house and uh just that
that's a joke too.
Dude,
we're crying about this. Why would
anybody be upset? He said it was a joke.
Why would you be mad about that? Why
would anybody be mad about that? And to
add salt to the wound, he is not above
making baseless claims. He [__] about
[__] Willie Mack making that baseless
claim, but is not above forming an
entire [__] skitsoid conspiracy
theory based on again literally nothing.
>> The guy is like as far as I can tell
like total grift of scum. The guy is
like I mean he spent the whole first
video on Destiny was almost like
basically co-written by notite. This guy
was in DMs talking back and forth to
notite. He's sitting there encouraging
him to go after Sunday. Stir Destiny.
And you can see obviously why like she's
still hanging around Destiny. She still
wants his image good.
>> Uh Willie fell for it. Was a total mark.
Um play played the game exactly the way.
>> Hey, there is proof of this claim and
I've I've already talked to the person
who has proof and uh I told them what
I'll say right now. I think I think
leaking it early before the video drops
uh for [__] Gilded Poo for a sub 1k
view video is a bit of a waste.
Um, but yeah, I think uh it's going to
be leaked either way. It's going to be
leaked in my video. It's going to be
leaked in the person who has the
information's video. Uh, or it's going
to be leaked on Twitter in like the
morning if he decides to leak it to, uh,
you know, dispel the criticism, this
specific critique against. So, it's
going to be leaked regardless. But yes,
I can say with an air of certainty uh,
or with absolute certainty. In fact, I
will say with an absolute certainty that
yes, Willie Mack was in DMs with
Aerodite. Willie Mack was talking with
Aerodite and that formed a large portion
of his video in in specific the Sunday
section, right? Uh the same way that
Willie Mack was in DMs with Destiny when
Destiny told Willy that Queman uh spread
his docs or Queman's fans spread his
docks or whatever and he just took that
and spread it uncritically uh and then
essentially smeared Queman.
So yes, this is not this is this is a
pattern of behavior to be clear. This is
a pattern of behavior. This is Willie
Mack's show.
uh being told by two content creators in
private uh you know in DMs with them uh
and it it formed a significant portion
of their content. So this is just this
is just correct. This is just true.
But you know obviously uh
you know whatever when the video is out
you'll be able to see the screenshot. I
guess I don't have permission to leak it
first, but I guess uh
I'm not above talking about it because I
mean Queman's obviously in this clip
talking about it and the video is going
to be out in like, you know, relatively
soon. So, who [__] cares?
>> I wanted him to. I'm telling you for a
fact, the reason that President's Sunday
section is there is because Willie Mack
contacted Erodite and had Erdite tell
him 90% of the story. She guided him
through making that video. She was
working with Sunday and Kilo.
>> Jesus Christ, I'm shaking. Sorry.
>> I don't see what the point is here with
that. So, you're saying, "Okay,
>> let's saywards
trying to create a PRP for Destiny
fundamentally." That's what everyite
wanted and willy let her let her do it
basically.
>> Which by the way, the only way that
skitso theory could even work at all
whatsoever is if Queenman had access to
DMs, which he doesn't have. The same
lack of access he uses as an excuse to
not comment on the cherry and just ilk
drama that was happening. Wait.
Burn. Dude, the comments. I just got
DM'd a comment. Burn. The world is
saying W. This guy got All of these
people are just flamed by Queenman.
Aside from the weird anti-Semitic
comment at the start. This is a great
video. I had no idea Quean was such a
bad person. Gilded responds, "It was
meant to be a jab at his frequent
attempts at hiding his Jewish ethnicity
for views.
I recognize that doesn't translate well
in the video. I'm far too pro-Israel to
actually be anti-semitic.
I hope the next person who starts making
these videos on me is less disabled than
you and Vincent. Feel free to call in
after this airs.
Wow,
dude. So [__]
around the same time. If they both
leaked through all their DMs, maybe I'd
be able to come to a conclusion here,
but I I just can't. I'm not going to say
Cherry's totally right and Jay looks a
piece of [__]
>> This limey [__] is incapable of being
consistent on literally anything.
Okay. Relationship drama is not the same
as a [__] production of a YouTube
video. What are you talking about?
Okay. Yes. You can't come to the
conclusion that someone is abusive from
one-sided DMs that don't showcase abuse
and then them repeatedly saying, "Oh,
they're abusive. They're abusive.
They're abusive." Listen, I like Cherry,
but how is [__] anybody how is
anybody supposed to come to the
conclusion that Jay's dog's abusive from
the [__] that she released? You would
obviously need more context. You can't
come to a solid conclusion from that
evidence provided. Now I will say okay I
will say on the other hand
uh I think Queman I think maybe maybe a
good argument could be made okay that
Queen talking about the Aerodite thing
without providing proof and just you
know relying on his word or something is
a little is a little gay okay um but I
don't think that's an inconsistency I
disagree that that's an inconsistency
obviously if you're shown DMs and they
don't prove something like yeah your
your default is going to be like no I
don't think They're abusive unless you
show me more evidence that showcases
like abuse, right?
Okay. Well, I I I need to rew I need to
make sure I'm not
>> doesn't have the same lack of access. He
uses as an excuse to not comment on the
cherry and just ilk.
>> Hey, what does he say in I got to
>> Okay.
>> Let's say
trying to create a PR piece for Destiny
fundamentally. if that's what everyite
wanted and willy let her let her do it
basically.
>> Which by the way, the only way that
skitso theory could even work at all
whatsoever is if Queenman had access to
DMs, which he doesn't have. The same
lack of access he uses as an excuse to
not comment. Uh, okay, this is actually
slightly good point actually. Okay, it's
not inconsistent in that he is uh I
disagree with the inconsistency, but
yeah, he probably shouldn't have talked
about the Aerodite [__] without it being
public
>> on the Cherry and Just Ik drama that was
happening around the same time. If they
both like filled at DMs, maybe I'd be
>> No, this is mostly fine. I just disagree
with it being inconsistent. This is
these these are not these are not
similar enough situations for this to be
an inconsistency.
Cherry accusing someone of abuse is very
different than like the production of a
YouTube video. I don't believe this is
inconsistent. I do I understand the
point that he's trying to make though. I
do think the point is fine. I just don't
think it's an inconsistency.
>> Come to a conclusion here, but I I just
can't I'm not going to say Cherry's
totally right. And Jay's a piece of
[__]
>> This limey [__] is incapable of being
consistent on literally anything. How
could he have possibly addressed the
Willie Mack doxing situation without
being accused of dog whistling? How
could I have made the point I made about
Willie Mack without being accused of dog
whistling to swat his wedding? How could
I have what is a way I could have
phrased that point that Destiny's
standards leave his own supporters and
fans open to being doxed and harassed?
Harassed.
How could I have phrased that to where
Willie Mack could not have accused me of
dog whistling in the way he did? There
is not a single way
I could have phrased that where he
wouldn't be able to make that same
allegation.
>> I don't know Quean. Maybe by not making
that point at all.
W critique.
[Laughter]
Genius. Genius.
Dude.
Okay. Yeah. This is epic. This is good.
Queen is [__] raped, bro. It's
[__] over. Listen, I put my eggs in
the wrong basket, folks.
point that Destiny's standards leave his
own supporters and fans open to being
doxed and harassed. Harassed.
How could I have phrased that to where
Willie Mack could not have accused me of
dog whistling in the way he did? There
is not a single way
I could have phrased that where he
wouldn't be able to make that same
allegation.
>> I don't know Quean. Maybe by not making
that point at all. One.
>> Okay. Maybe he saves it. Maybe he saves
it. Let's keep going.
>> Way that might have really saved you in
this situation is by either a saying,
"Fuck, I'm sorry to hear that. That's
kind of [__] up. I don't believe in no
bad tactics, only bad targets. And I
don't think you should have been treated
that way.
>> Has Quean not said this?
I'm pretty sure Queenman has said that,
"Yeah, it's [__] that Willie got doxed
and it's [__] that that shit's out
there.
I'm pretty sure he said that." And then
move the topic along. Or if that's too
gay for you.
>> Well, yeah, because he's not critiquing
Willie. He's obviously critiquing
Destiny who's saying something [__]
Just don't address it at all. You
[__] s Just don't address.
Okay.
>> There bloating. You were smiling from
ear to ear. Your response was literally
Willie Mack deserved it. That was
essentially what you said.
What?
No. No. That's not what he said. That's
not what he said. No. Gilded.
Gilded.
No. Okay. the crew. Okay. Where where is
uh hold on hold on. Where is uh
here we go. Here we go. Gilded, if
you're watching, this is for you. Okay.
The critique here is not that Willie
deserves it. It's actually the opposite,
right? Because doxing is bad. There's no
excuse for doxing. Okay?
There's no excuse for doxing. Doxing is
bad. Full stop. It doesn't matter if the
person's a [__] pedophile or a
murderer or whatever. Internet
vigilantism is generally never going to
end well. All right, we can look at
examples like
um [__] EDP. He was mega doxed. His
shit's out there. We know for a fact he
was trying to meet up with like a
12-year-old or something or 13-year-old
or our old she was and he's still out
there. He's not in jail, right? Internet
vigilantism does not work. You need to
go to the police if you have something
against someone, right? So whether it's
doxing Willie, whether it's doxing
Destiny, whether it's doxing [__]
Jtock or or even me or any of these
people, doxing is not going to do
anything. Doxing is purely a method of
uh intimidation. It is a intimidation
tactic to [__] with people online. That
is it. Acting like there is a morally
just way or morally just reason to dox
someone uh is [__] Okay? Doxing is
purely used as a tool to [__] with
someone. That is what doxing is. It does
not serve as any other tool. It doesn't
like there there is no issue that doxing
could potentially solve that calling the
police or contacting the authorities
would solve better. Okay.
Can we get the cat tummy gift for
sanity? Yeah, sure. I got to remember
which one it is. There we go. There we
go. Tell me on day one, folks. Tell me
on day one.
So when Destiny says anything involving
this be guy or anyone that supports him
is justifiable, it's obviously [__]
because Destiny has a history a years
long history of doxing people of doxing
people and doxing people who associate
with certain people. food shops who is a
Destiny orbiter who's a Destiny fan has
even said uh that if you associate with
Queenman if you associate with JTOK it
is justifiable to dox you so the that is
what DGG's opinion is okay
what about the shadow government okay
well I haven't thought about that yet
okay I haven't thought about that yet
I I don't understand how the criticism
here is um
is like missing
like yes, Destiny should not be saying
this. Destiny is a doxer. Destiny will
try to dox people because they they are
critical of him.
And then obviously the the response by
someone in DGG would be like, okay,
well, they're targeting his um they're
targeting his livelihood. They're
targeting his job. All right.
Um tsue is uh Queen hasn't done that.
Now, I think Jtock has to be fair. I
think JTock has said that Destiny should
be like should not stream or something,
but I think Jtock is a little I will say
I will I I I think JTO is slightly
compromised in that aspect uh because of
Cherry.
He didn't really care about the Destiny
stuff until the Cherry stuff was outed.
Uh and then he started going really hard
and apparently he's said that he thinks
uh Destiny should stop streaming and
stuff. So, I do think he's slightly
compromised. I don't dislike him. I I
still like JTO. I'm not going to like I
I still like him. Um but yeah, if you
even if you associate with Jtock, even
if JTO's opinion is Destiny shouldn't be
allowed to stream, I don't think that
makes it so you should be doxed, right?
I think doxing should be off the table.
I think this is internet drama. You
should solve it with internet [__] You
should try solve it with with [__]
internet [__] talk. That's all this is.
And bringing like real life uh aspects
into it, addresses, names, um whatever
it may be.
I think is uh is [__] because that can
lead to real world that can lead to real
world home uh home [__] [__] [__] that
can lead to real world harm real world
consequences. Does that make sense?
Would Destiny be saying
that those
>> gay little [__] dox people,
>> those who make calls to violence or
illusions to violence should be fair
game and all of their supporters and all
of their supporters. Bro is smiling from
ear to ear the entire time as doxing
information.
Is he smiling because of the doxing
information or is he smiling because of
the absur the absurd concept uh that he
is uh verbally expressing. Can we think
about this for like two seconds? Maybe
>> the [__] background behind him. Maybe
just don't do that. If you believe that
the principle of no bad tactics only bad
targets is a bad principle, then it
shouldn't matter who the target is. If
the tactic is bad, it's bad. Notice that
at no point, by the way, in that clip,
does he condemn any of the doxers
involved, not even the act of doxing, he
only can is that true?
I don't think that's true. I think
Queman in in that stream does say doxing
is bad and you shouldn't dox. I could be
wrong. I don't know. Is the VOD up?
[__] I don't remember if the VOD got
private because of the doc [__]
Um
Can we even find it?
Okay. [__] no clue what that is.
Jesus Christ. Misspell.
When would it have even been? It could.
Dude, someone literally Oh my god. [__]
Queen. I was literally going to make a
thumbnail like this. I was literally
going to make a thumbnail like this for
my [__] main channel video, but now
he's [__] done it, dude. Piece of
[__] When would it have been
cries doxing over Jtock retweet? It
wouldn't be this, right?
>> Is it this?
>> What if he's
>> No.
>> When they
When would it have God, it's so long ago
at this point.
Okay, I'm I'm spending so much time. If
someone has the VOD or the the edited
video or even a longer clip, send it
over. I'm not going to keep looking for
it. I'm pretty sure I watched that
stream live. I'm pretty sure he does say
doxing is bad in it. I could be wrong. I
don't know.
>> Condemns Willie Mac and Destiny.
>> I just asked the user with Queen. I
mean, if Queman has the stream or the
VOD, yeah, just send it to me. I'll look
at it.
>> What he did was effectively
>> I don't remember when it had to have
been like a month or even at this point
two months ago. Probably like a month
and a half. No, it'd be close to two
months ago. It It was a while ago that
this all happened, I think.
>> Victim blaming. Not that I give a [__]
about that, but that's what he did. It
doesn't really
>> If you don't give a [__] then why are
you saying it?
>> Seem very consistent with your alleged
values whatsoever. In fact, to really
hammer this point home, here is his
reaction to Nicholas Dioro cancelling a
podcast or some [__] [__] because
Dan, a Destiny Orbiter, was doxing
people. And this is what Queman had to
say in response to Nicholas Dioro's
tweet on that situation. can't even
bring himself to take a doxing bad
stance. He cannot bring himself to take
a doxing bad calling people at work bad
stance. The only time I ever see you say
doxing is bad is whenever it's your
enemies that are the ones doing the
doxing. But when your enemies are the
ones getting doxed, you don't really
seem to give much of a [__] If the
tactic is bad, it's bad regardless of
who the target is, according to your
value.
>> I don't watch bad empanada. I'm not a
big bad empanada viewer. So, I hadn't
seen this video in full. I didn't know
the contents of of this clip.
>> No, no discussing of any real or
fictional children's age in chat. By the
way, guy, I'm putting a firm ban on
that. I think it's uh I don't want to I
don't want to give any strong critiques
on uh on children. I think that's uh bad
to do. I don't think we should do that.
So, no discussing of any real children,
whomever they be may be offspring of.
No, no discussing that, please.
>> Intimately,
>> I I deleted the messages. I won't ban
anybody, but if it happens again, I'll
do like a 24-hour ban. If it continues
to happen, I'll do a perma ban. I don't
want any discussion of that.
>> Um, intimately. That's a very
interesting choice of words there, Quan.
After saying that you didn't know the
contents, which by the way, don't worry
because not even 30 seconds later, he
says the following. Obviously, I knew
what the clip was about because I mean,
everyone was talking about how Willie
Mack had been doxed.
>> So, what he's saying is is that he was
fully aware of the contents of the clip
and just didn't give a [__]
>> Not to mention, of course, this was
weeks after William Mack had already
been doxed that this clip happened, the
original docks.
So, the idea they contributed in any way
is absurd on the face of it. Now, to be
fair to Quimman, yet again, there is no
evidence to substantiate the claim that
his community was the community that
posted that doxing information on Kiwi
Farms. However, I should point out here
that there is really no reason for you
to mention that that was released on
Kiwi Farms weeks previously when, as you
said yourself in the video, that you
only heard about it after Bad Empanada
released it for everybody to see. So, I
don't really understand why you're
mentioning how many weeks went by. Why
are you even bringing that up? It's a
bit disingenuous. It feels
>> how what
>> feels like you're trying to muddy the
waters as to how culpable you actually
are in the spreading of said doxing
information.
Okay. How how culpable is Queenman if
bad and Panata produces a video it gets
like 70k views.
What's the video at now? Uh [__]
uh slop tuber. Yeah, 70k views.
And then Destiny's tweet, it's deleted
at this point, but it got upwards of
like 300K. I think it was at like 270K
by the time that I saw it or was able to
get a screenshot of it.
What What is Queenman's culpability
there? at what point uh you know cuz at
this at this point I don't know dude
[Music]
no he's not culpable at all. Bad
empanada posted the video.
Um
Destiny made the tweet that got hundreds
of thousands of views. I don't think
he's culpable.
Honestly, I I agree with uh [__]
what's his name? Junk drawer Gaming's
position where you know Quean could have
could have handled it better on stream.
He could have you know if you're if
you're dealing with doc [__] if you're
dealing with dosh [__] especially when
you're you know criticizing the doxing
or the what's revolving around the
doxing or whatever it may be. I think
you you can be more safe about it. You
could have gotten a screenshot of it and
then like you know put a black box over
the you know the video or whatever.
But at the same time, I think um the
responsibility you have on stream is a
little different than you have in
prepared content, right? Um
yeah, no, Cayman could have handled it
better, but saying he's he's culpable or
more or less culpable in the doxing is
[__] at this point. Destiny is a
insanely massive creator. Destiny
uh is is probably the reason why most
people know about that clip is because
of Destiny.
And also Willie Matt crashing out out of
and then also making the [__] video
recently. So
I don't think Queen has any culpability
for the spread of the information.
Absolutely not.
>> Which by the way he's
obviously not absolute like probably
sure there's probably like a couple
people that only found out about it from
a queen and stream but at you know at
the point uh that we were at no it who
cares. Destiny had already talked about
it. Uh bad empanada had already posted
the video. Destiny tweeted about the
bottom but not a video.
I don't think you have a significant
responsibility to not talk about it when
massive creators are then talking about
it. Right?
At what point uh are we supposed to just
continue ignoring something when massive
creators like Destiny are able to uh you
know loudly and proudly speak about it I
guess is the point, right? Where do you
draw the line where it's like okay this
is fine to talk about now, right?
not really that culpable. Like he does
make a good point in that it was already
viral by the time he talked about it, so
it doesn't really matter all that much.
But to claim that you're 0% culpable,
which is kind of what he's doing there,
is a bit dishonest, which I find to be
interesting because of the following
clip. The idea that I am getting blamed
for that live when I censored it in the
upload got throwaway to censor it on
Twitter. Even though I usually don't
control the people that [__] clip my
[__] at all. I know I don't like making
recommendations to them or anything like
that. I still went out on a way to fix
that. If your culpability was 0% then
what was there to fix?
Wow.
Clement is not dog whistling to an
audience of doxers, but in fact is
rewarding an audience of doxers.
All right, I need a break. I need to
[__] give me like This is false. Cats
have that flap. Cats have that little
pouch,
okay?
Uh to store fat during the winter.
All right? So, it does not mean that
that cat used to be obese. It means that
that cat lives in a variable climate.
All right? Whereas, if you see a cat
maybe in a tropical climate, areas like
uh California or Florida and stuff like
that, they likely won't have that. Uh
but cats living somewhere like Canada or
uh maybe in Europe where it gets colder
and then hotter and the the you know the
weather v uh you know has variation
between hot and cold like a winter
season.
Oh, they'll get that. That sounds true.
I mean you can literally just Google it.
That's what that pouch is for. It is for
storing fat during the winter
because they can't find uh they can't
find uh a lot of food often times. Um,
so they'll usually right before winter
the cat will bulk up and it'll gain fat
in that pouch and then throughout the
winter it'll slowly lose, you know, the
weight because he's, you know, using the
fat stored there. Hackers and doxers
have been essentially supplementing his
content or at least his Destiny coverage
this entire time. But before I get into
the really nitty-gritty of why I think
it is that he A is rewarding doxers and
B doesn't even care about doxing really
at all. Anyway, I need to point out that
Destiny actually predicted what was
going to happen to Willie Mack 3 months
ago.
>> Yes, but he's saying that because you
won't come out and post a video like
unequivocally calling me like a mass.
This is what they do. So, whatever like
you're working on right now is aed waste
of time because if you post this, you're
going to have Hassan's community. You're
going to have these people. That's fine.
But you say that now, but it'll turn
into them going after you and then
they'll try to dox you or your
girlfriend or they'll go after family or
they'll go after friends of yours or
they'll go after.
>> Again, to be clear,
my critique of Willie
is not that he's not calling Destiny a
[__] rapist. It's that he's
downplaying what Destiny had done and
giving him a path to redemption.
He's trying to say that Destiny has no
pattern of abuse when there obviously
is. Right? That is my issue. And then he
also lied in his videos.
other people in the commentary community
until they make videos about you. Like
this is what they This is like the
pattern. It is soing irritating. Yeah.
Look at Willie Mac's [__] face. He's
like cocky. He doesn't care. He did not
see this coming. If I were one of these
doxers, I would love that anytime I dock
somebody that Queman doesn't like that
Queman will be all smiles. That would
almost be encouraging. I don't. But
Queman didn't cover the docks when it
came out. He covered a Destiny tweet
criticizing Destiny.
Okay, Queman didn't cover Willy's docs.
Quean never covered Willy's docs. Queman
criticized a Destiny tweet.
>> Don't think he actually gives an
almighty [__] about doxing at all in the
first place. So why do I say that? Well,
literally today he did a stream where he
said this about Dan.
>> Dan is an open lie. Dan is an open
doctor. Dan's kind of a piece of [__] a
lot of the time. Dan doesn't give a [__]
about morals or principles. He's just
about like how do I win? He gets off on
commanding an internet army. Almost all
of his, you know, behavior on the
internet can be explained by the through
the lens of a middle-aged man desperate
for the feeling of power and importance
trying to weaponize the brigade of
internet followers that he's got in
order to to muster that perception and
master that feeling in himself. Like
there's no guiding principle. There's no
evaluation of the world that's
happening. Like I I'll say exactly what
Dan is. But I love Dan. Okay, I do love
Dan. Look, look, look, look.
>> So much for having principles, bro.
>> Now I have principles. I
>> You can think something's bad and then
still be friends with someone who does
it.
Now again, I say I don't think Queen and
Dan are friends. I bet you know. You
know what I mean? You know what I mean?
Now, I I have lines. I don't think I
would befriend someone who's uh who's an
active doxer.
I wouldn't care if they're like
reformed. Okay. A salvo pancakes type. I
love that guy. All right. Um but yeah,
like I would never be friends with
someone like Dan. I would never be
friends with someone like uh like
personal friends. Obviously, like
content [__] is different. Like I' I'd
talk to people on stream. I'd talk to
Dan on stream. I'd talk to Destiny on
stream. I would talk to anybody who
doxes on stream. I don't care. But like
a close personal friendship I would not
do with someone who's actively doxing.
But yeah, acting like you can't like
Yeah, you can still have principles
against something. That's not what a
principle means. A principle me doesn't
mean like if someone does something that
you're against, you can't be their
friend or you can't like them. That's
not what that means.
Like a lot of the music artists that I
listen to are like terrible people, but
I'll still like listen to their music. I
think their music's cool. Like
this is [__] Whatever, dude.
Whatever, dude. I don't even care.
>> They have principles, but boy, do I love
this absolute piece of [__] However, if
that was the extent of my evidence, that
would be pretty weak. Enter Salvo
Pancakes. Remember uh the the the old
Queenman uh Sal I [__] called up
Salvo. I did it live on one of his
patrons.
>> I'll take that. I'll take that. I love
Salvo. So what does Queman have to say
about Salvo Pancakes? Somebody that you
could argue is the Sudam Hussein of
commentary.
>> Now what? I hear he did leak Nuro's
phone number and that's obviously
totally [__] up. like um that that is
like totally [__] up and leaking
people's like personal [__] contact
info is you know I get why you would
totally cut someone off and make them
persona non grata for doing that.
However, he was really funny. He did do
some really really funny streams. So
clearly
>> what's wrong with anything that he said
there?
>> Quan does not give an almighty [__]
about doxing. But you see like most
things it only gets worse from here.
Quean likes to go on rants about reduced
agency. It's like he almost loves that
[__] line for some reason. Here's a
clip of him using it. Now,
>> almost every case where there is someone
who targets a specific age range, I
think it's predatory because I don't
know why you're targeting that specific
age range or the or mentally ill people
other than the reduced agency generally.
That that seems to be the case.
>> That makes people like Destiny
predators. Okay. What if I told you that
salvo? All right. Someone literally made
a chart.
Where is this? Some [__] DM this to
me.
Hopefully it's a PNG. I can pull it up
on stream
and now it's text.
Okay.
Molina. Destiny was 30. Molina was 20.
There's a 10-year age difference. Rose.
Destiny was 33.
He thought Rose was 19, which is a
14-year age difference.
Uh, Pixie is early 20s. Destiny was 30.
So, around like a, you know, 8 to 10
year age difference.
Uh, there's another one. I don't know
who this girl is, so I won't say her
name, but she's 18. Destiny's 31, 13
year age difference.
Lauren Southern 25, 31, you know, 6 year
age difference, mid20s.
Lav was 23, Destiny was 33, 10 year age
difference.
There's another one. 21 35 14year age
So acting as if like Yeah, there is a
bit of a pattern here. There is a bit of
a pattern here. There 1,00% is a bit of
a pattern here. And it's so funny.
Someone sent this to me. I was talking
with someone. And I was like, "What if
we did like a chart that showed like the
age difference between by all the women
that Destiny's like pursued publicly?"
Then he DM' me today and he's like,
"Here, someone just made it." So, yeah.
No, there is a pattern. There's 10,000%
a pattern of Destiny going after women
in their late teens, early 20s.
Um, is that predatory? Uh, predatory.
Uh, maybe, maybe it can be. I don't
know. I'd have to think about it.
I think at at first glance, yeah, at
first glance, yeah, that's predatory.
Why are you, as a, you know, early 30s
guy specifically targeting women who
are, you know, just out of high school,
early 20s.
Like, yeah, I think most people would
describe that as predatory. You are
specifically going after women who have
less life experience than you. Now, to
be clear, to be clear, as a 30-year-old
going after a 20-year-old or like a 30,
not as, but a 30-year-old going after a
20-year-old
is not always predatory,
but having like an an exclusive like,
you know, whatever, like specifically
targeting those women, specifically
targeting younger women is predatory.
I think
I agree with that. I agree with that
completely.
pancakes specifically targeted a
mentally ill girl. And when I say
targeted, I mean made her drink her
piss.
>> Let me ask you a question. All right.
>> Is he falling for the Keemstar bit?
Oh, dude. Okay. Keemstar literally did
like a [__] a campaign against Salvo.
Jesus. Okay, this is this is rough. Am I
too penis brainer? Is 10 years not that
bad? No, 10 years is not that bad.
10 year Okay, again, if it's if it's if
a 30-year-old dating a 20-year-old, who
[__] cares? A 30-year-old dating a
40-year-old, who cares? A 40-year-old
dating a 20-year-old, who cares? Who?
Like, that's not bad. But if you're 30
and you're specifically targeting women
who are in their early 20s, right? If
you're specifically targeting women who
are in their late teens, early 20s, then
yes, that is predatory because it it has
to be the case in my mind. It has to be
the case that you are specifically
targeting women who have less life
experience than you, right?
Who you have who who you intrinsically
have a a power imbalance over.
So, no, 10 years isn't bad, but it can
be bad. The same way like um anything
like as a rule, no, it's not bad, but it
can be, right?
As a rule, it obviously can be.
One point in this sexing, did you make a
girl lick pee out of the toilet and on
the ground?
>> No, because I can't make anybody do
anything from a phone. Okay. Did you ask
somebody to do that? How about that?
>> Um,
>> honestly, I don't think it's the
maturity level they care about. It's the
body, isn't it? Yes, that's true. But
how do they get how do they get to the
point where they can like, you know,
have sexual intercourse or have sexual
contact with this person, right? You
obviously have to talk to them. And if
you're 30 years old, it's probably going
to be easier for you to, you know, use
your life experience or things that
you've discovered and whatever your life
to get with someone who's like early
20s, right? Probably going to be easier
for you to do. So, if you are 30 and
you're specifically targeting women who
you know you're going to have a power
imbalance over and you know you're going
to be able to convince to have sex with
you and whatever, again, it's not
intrinsically bad, right? But you are
you are targeting a vulnerability, I I
believe, which does make it predatory.
Does that suddenly mean that the
20-year-old women that Destiny's
interacting with suddenly have zero
[__] agency and they really were
getting raped the whole time? No,
obviously not. If you're 20 years old
and a 30-year-old pursues you and you
choose to have sex with them, it's
obviously on you. You probably wanted to
have sex with a 30-year-old. Uh, but I
think it does speak to the 30-year-old
if they are specifically targeting
younger people, if they're specifically
targeting like late teens, early 20s.
Again, as a rule, it is not bad, but it
can be bad, I think. Or it can be bad.
Uh, I don't know if it can be bad. Might
be too charged. You know what I mean?
Hopefully. Hopefully I'm explaining
properly.
>> Again, I didn't see the text.
>> Okay. No, that's [__] That's
[__] Dali, that's [__] Power
imbalances are not [__] intrinsically
bad. It doesn't matter if you're a
streamer dating a fan. It doesn't matter
if you're a [__] fan of an actor or
if you're dating a a manager at a
co-work like a manager at your job or
whatever. That's not the type of power
imbalance I'm talking about. Talking
about life experience. You being a
streamer doesn't really affect uh your
relationship with your partner that
much. Whereas if you're 30 and they're
20, I feel like your life experience uh
differs a lot in in terms of you know
whatever.
I don't think job power and balances
really matter that much. But life
experience and and what you've
experienced through your life. You are
10 years older than this person.
Whatever. I think that experience that
that matters
>> message is
>> no they do power imbalances aren't bad.
Every relationship is going to have a
power imbalance. Every relationship ever
is going to have a power imbalance.
That's why when people you know
criticize a relationships uh for power
imbalances. I think it's generally
pretty [__] because every single
relationship ever is going to have a
power imbalance.
I don't think that's a good line of
critique and that's not what I'm criti
I'm not saying power imbalance uh you
know on its own. I'm saying Destiny has
significantly more life experience,
right, than like women in their early
20s or late teens.
>> Um, but I'll take your word for it. Did
I say that?
>> Okay. Okay. So, the the woman that did
that told Clara that um you know that
she has all I wish Clara was here to
better represent the story, but the way
I remember it is the woman has a lot of
mental disabilities. All right. That did
this with you. All right. and she feels
like she's been taken advantage. Her
family feels like she's been taken
advantage of. This is a 20-year-old
girl, by the way, and she's now been put
in like some type of home because she's
so embarrassed about what she did for
you that she suic
messages to prove that I didn't know
that she felt uncomfortable at to me. I
didn't make any of this public. And um
all that I knew from literally until the
moment that this came out was that she
had no problem with me. So
>> he's not even denying it actually at
all. He's just basically sitting there
like I didn't realize until just now she
was upset by it. But
I I I I know nothing about the [__]
salvo pancakes piss [__] I couldn't
tell you. You remember the anti- Destiny
moral crusade that I mentioned earlier
that Queman has been going on about for
the better part of six months? Well,
part of that crusade was Destiny
allegedly recording sexual encounters
without the consent to record. What are
the odds that our buddy, our palo
pancakes did exactly the same thing? The
allegation is you went to Niagara,
hooked up with this girl tour, and she
while you were uh hitting it from
behind, she turned around and you were
on your phone
to record her.
>> No, I already I already said no.
>> What were you doing on your phone?
>> I think I was checking like YouTube
Studio.
>> Okay, so you definitely did hook up with
this girl.
>> Uh I I don't I don't know about that
one. Probably another lie.
Well, you just admitted that you hooked
up with her.
>> No, you told me a story and I said I
didn't film anybody. I don't know who I
hooked up with.
>> So, unless you want to believe the
hands.
Okay. What What is this supposed to be
proof of that he's recording women
without their consent? This is [__]
dude.
This suck. Okay. Obviously, Salvo is
different from Destiny. There is there
is significantly differences there. And
even so, Salva can do something that
you're principally against and then
still like him, still think he's funny.
I think Nick Fuentes is funny. Is he
also a white supremacist that would like
want me [__] killed and raped and
hung and strung and skinned? Yeah,
probably. I think Bad Empanada is funny.
Would he dox me the second I, you know,
publicly go against him? Yeah, probably.
Do I think Bad Empanada is a terrible
person? Are you a mut? Okay. Come on,
buddy. Come on, pal. I'm actually
blazian. I'm like I look like Markiplier
except black. Blackface Markiplier. Is
there an image of that? Blackface
Markiplier.
No images of Mark and blackface. This is
not looking good. There's no way you're
blazing.
You'll never know.
>> Caught in the cookie jar level excuse
that he gave that. Oh, he was just
casual. Freddy is Blazian. [__] off.
Freddy is not blazing.
You're lying. You're a lying piece of
[__] Gilded Poo's right about you.
Freddy is not [__] Blazian, dude.
Don't say that [__]
>> Perusing his YouTube studio app while
boinking some [__] He was doing
exactly what he was accused of doing.
Come on. And with all of that in He was
doing exactly what he was accused of
doing. Is there any You're just going
There's no What are you talking about?
Was there any evidence for that claim at
all? Was there any what? What the [__]
What the [__] Hands caught in the
cookie jar level excuse that he gave
that. Oh, he was just casually perusing
his YouTube studio app while boinking
some [__] He was doing exact.
>> Has there been a video leak? Has he
confirmed this? Like what? What are you
going off of here?
He's denying he's denying even ever
having slept with her.
And with all of that in mind, I want
you, the audience, to remember that
Queman and Salvo Pancakes are best
friends right now.
>> Me and Salvo are very good friends
already. Okay.
>> No,
no,
no.
[Laughter]
Dude,
come on. And with all of that in mind, I
want you, the audience, to remember that
Queman and Salvo Pancakes are best
friends right now.
>> Me and Salvo are very good friends
already. Okay, first of all, so don't
even attempt to drive a wedge like that
cuz we're very good friends already.
>> Yeah. So, it's very,
>> dude.
He's he's he's [__] he's pinned the
the tail on the donkey with this one,
dude. He's pinned the tail on the
donkey. very apparent to me that Queman
doesn't give a [__] about things like
doxing. You know, given the fact that he
likes Dan, despite the fact that Dan
apparently doxes people,
you can like someone if they do
something you disagree with.
We love Dan. We love Dan if we ignore
what he did in Hawaii. Okay? If we
ignore what Dan did in Hawaii, we love
him. The moment that gets brought into
the conversation, things get a little
more things get a little a little
different. Okay. I'm trying to think who
is someone that I'm like friendly with
that I disagree with on something.
I mean, I was open to talking to food
shops. I was open to talking to Glass. I
was open to talking to
uh Cameron.
Who else?
A Cheeto. I talked to a Cheeto on Queen
stream.
Like yeah, you can you can talk to
people. You can be friendly with people.
You can even like people that you're
you're critical of or you uh they do
something you you fundamentally disagree
with. Like a [__] point. Like no,
you can you can criticize your friends.
You can criticize people you like. You
can criticize people who you think are
funny. Who cares? Femro.
Do I have like an intrinsic disagreement
with fe? Well, I think I think fem are
pedophiles. So I guess there is that. I
I guess there is that. Yeah.
>> And given the fact that Salvo Pancakes
is literally infamous for doxing people
on live streams, and let's be real here,
criticizing Nicholas Dioro for not
bitching at Dan loud enough for doxing
and bitching about Dan doxing and
bitching about Destiny doxing people
really falls flat when you're bffs with
literally Sudam Hussein. going after
Destiny for quote being a predator by
going after mentally ill women and also
going after Destiny for non-consensually
recording and sharing pornography kind
of falls flat whenever a Okay, is there
proof that Salvo did that? Is there
proof that Salvo has a history of
targeting these women? Is there proof
that Salvo unconsensually recorded a sex
act? Because if that if there is proof
of that, yeah, I think that's pretty
damning. But is there any proof of that?
He's denying even ever having slept with
this girl,
right? It's like, no, Destiny and Salvo
are not one to one. Even Even if Salvo
did that, I think the severity there is
obviously significantly less than what
Destiny did. It's still bad. To be
clear, I'm not trying to downplay what
Salvo did. Um, if he did that, which I
don't think he did. There's just no
evidence of I don't want like obviously
whatever
stream your
>> girls leaked the sex and there was no
videos. Yeah. I mean, if there's there's
just no evidence of Salvo unconsensually
recording anybody to my knowledge,
>> with Salvo Pancakes ends like this.
>> I appreciate you. I want to circle back
with you in one month. I'm going to have
you on once a month and we're going to
kumbaya and we're going to laugh
together and uh we'll get along. I
appreciate you coming on. I'm not going
to keep you any longer. Uh if you have
any last words for me, any compliments
for me, I'll take them. Any compliments
for the show, I also will take that.
I'll take anything. No. Look, good luck.
Listen, I hope you stay on YouTube this
time, man. I like your stream. So, luck
luck luck.
Wow. W
[Music]
You got to shorten the title card
length. You got to shorten it down a
little bit. Come on, Vod. What are we
doing here? How [__] long is this
title card? Before I end the video
today, I want to bring up a couple
points. It's really strange that Queman
privated not one, not 10, not 30, but
600 plus VODs. And he did so not even a
couple weeks after his response to Willy
Mac. But
okay. Um,
no, I don't care. I don't care about
that at all.
You can't you can't control what happens
on your stream and YouTube often changes
their toos and then they'll target older
videos, you know, whatever. I think it's
fine if you delete VODs, if you private
VODs. Who cares? Who gives a [__] If
you really care, [__] download the
streams, you know, when they go
unlisted, download them, archive them
yourself. What's even more interesting
is he didn't just private an entire
backlog. He also picked two very
specific dates for which he privated a
whole host of streams in between. That
is between the 13th and the 30th of
July. So I have no idea why he privated
all of those VODs. Let
>> uh I think he said on stream before it's
like after two months or whatever he'll
go through and private or whatever. I
believe
>> alone the VODs between those two very
specific dates, but I'll leave that
knowledge and the speculation entirely
up to you. And secondly, it's entirely
possible that Queen and Pals may label
me as a Destiny defender or a Willie
Mack defender.
>> No, you you you
made some like [__] points. I don't
think you care about either of those
people
>> in order to dismiss everything that I've
said. And if so,
>> what have you even said? You've said
like he's a hypocrite because Salvo
Pancakes was not and then also Salvo
Pancakes were the [__] recording
[__] And then you can understand how
Willie came to the conclusion that he
did. These are not like strong points
that people would need to dismiss.
>> Though I would be very surprised if I
don't get doxed as a direct result.
What
defender or a Willie Mack defender in
order to dismiss everything that I've
said? And if so, I would be very
surprised if I don't get doxed as a
direct result. Thank you for watching
and if you liked this video, be sure to
like, subscribe, and all that other gay
[__] And if you really, really like the
video, please consider joining my
Patreon. On top of that, I also have a
Twitter account now, and you can of
course join my Discord linked down
below. I'd like to say thank you to all
of my patrons who naturally, of course,
made all of this possible. And
furthermore, if you don't want to join
my Discord or Twitter or any of that
other [__] and you just simply want to
watch another video, you should be
seeing one on the screen right now.
Thanks for watching, and go [__]
yourself.
Wow.